hi guys itself rats again and I just
realized that I just recorded this this
commentary and then audacity screwed up
somehow and didn't record it but anyway
so I'm going to do this all over again
and so basically what I'm doing right
here is I'm building a facade in between
the free fly coaster and the inverted
coaster since there are two that there's
supposed to be two entirely different
types of coasters but I felt like if I
didn't add something in between I
wouldn't have that border I wouldn't
have a smooth transition from one to the
other I didn't really want to see that
from that inverted coaster ride away
from the free fly coaster and vice versa
so I'm just building this facade right
here and it's still gonna be in the
style of the free fly coaster and I feel
I felt like adding a little Plaza with
houses around it and little towers and
fancy stuff around the first turn since
I figured now might as well try and I
I've been worrying about that first turn
for a while since I couldn't really come
up with anything interesting to place
over that I didn't just want to add
foliage to it I wanted to theme it's
about as heavily as the rest of the ride
and the rest of the right isn't themed
to the foliage it's actually the
buildings that are the most important
point so I really wanted to get that in
the beginning to ride away and this also
gives you a nice little view to look at
when you're in the when when you're in
the queue or on that path right there
next to the station so that's pretty
cool the only thing that I'm worried
about right now is the fact that this is
all looking kind of similar like
something is happening and this is
something that I'm very afraid of when
it comes to rollercoaster tycoon 3
building since I am building houses all
over the places many buildings in this
park which is actually something that I
wanted to do I wanted to add many
details and just mess with architecture
in this park but the only problem is
that I'm getting I'm getting used to
this style as ridiculous as it may sound
and it was probably a bad idea in
hindsight to do Alpine medieval
steampunk because it makes no sense
because steampunk part of steampunk by
the way is that Victorian architecture
or at least the industrial
and that's and both of those things are
some things that you can hardly do when
you're doing alpine or medieval and let
alone alpine medieval so that's one
problem that I have so it's it's kind of
turning out like it's all looking a bit
the same and I definitely don't want
that to happen so I'm glad that I
actually turned the entrance into a more
castle part and the free fly coast is
more alpine but I think that I'm gonna
tone it down on the buildings for the
inverts and just use other stuff because
otherwise it's gonna look too similar
now this is just me building that little
Plaza over there and I tried using
different terraforming things I realized
that that's that's one texture with the
Terra painting the sandstone I think it
is it's something that I definitely need
to use in this bike at some point it
looks really cool but the thing with
this plaza is also the fact that if you
just have ground well I see many people
doing is they spam grunts rubbery
because I don't know why it gives
something it gives you something to look
at but the problem is that in real life
or generally in the general sense of
things the ground isn't riddled with
flowers or anything like that how are
you gonna have handy man have to water
those things every day so that's not fun
so I figured I could just add a little
square thing over there to have
something to look at have some nice
scenery around it without making it look
ridiculous and unrealistic now this is
where I messed with the ethylene set by
the way in this building and then
decided to not do it because it can work
out quite as well as I thought it would
so I'm gonna resort to alpine again so
that kind of sucked
and then I was like you know what screw
that building so I'm just gonna work on
something else now I don't want to over
theme the inverts building wise but by
the way these Gables from Station Jim's
what is it what is it calling again
ghost cabins that are amazing but I
didn't want to over theme this ride
building wise but the only thing I had
was just this little this little thing
between the the helix and the loop was
just I could not not to be on the
building over there because it's just
perfect so that's what I messed with
that try to add some little windows in
quite work out try to add little cog
pipes then really work out so all that
gets removed at some point now that's
also something that I wanted to talk
about and it's actually had their
territory
HS designs rather taught me about the
fact that
steampunk isn't just in the copper and
the cogs which I thought about and I was
like yeah it isn't you can have a
perfectly steampunk building without any
cogs or pipes and there there is of
course the other mechanical stuff loads
of ironworks and other general
industrial things but then again there's
also the architectural style the
Victorian style that you have with
steampunk now I was like yeah that's all
cool and stuff but I am building a
medieval Alpine steampunk Park and then
I was like damn that's that's really
stupid now that makes no sense at all
because part of what steampunk is is
actually the architectural style so I
decided to yeah not do any of that and
do an Alpine medieval steampunk which
makes no sense that's one of the
problems that I have right here so I
definitely need to find some things out
to make this look steampunky without too
many clogs or pipes because I definitely
don't want to make this look like a
factory of any of of some sort so but it
works out pretty well though the
medieval slash Alpine works out somewhat
well when you when you mix the castle
walls into the Alpine buildings as you
see but the last thing that I'm gonna
have to do is actually get some
steampunk in there now this is something
that I tried which actually worked out
to some degree since it looked steampunk
cartilage and Alpine at the same time
but I removed this later on because the
idea behind this is that you have a big
tower on the lift hill that you can look
at from both the on ride of the inverts
and part underneath it and it shouldn't
look very impressive and high and all
that but it didn't quite work out the
way I wanted it to yeah in the end so I
just I decided to just remove it
and this is the this is the part where
I'm still wondering whether I should
actually be in this ride with buildings
and stuff or whether I should just add
foliage to it and I think I'm just gonna
go for the foliage because I don't want
to bother with more buildings down then
I've already tried and then removing
them in the end because what I feel is
that if I add too many buildings to this
I can add a building here and there but
if I had too many buildings to this it's
gonna end up looking like the rest of
the park and I don't want to create
something that's repetitive so I'm just
gonna make this some sort of a forest
not magical but some sort of a forest
something right I have no clue actually
but yeah this is so this is basically me
building buildings that I'm gonna remove
in the end but anyway that'll be it for
this episode so thank you so much for
watching and see you next time